[Applause]
uh blake and nick are at the old rickety
blake shelton podium and john and i are
at the well-constructed nick offerman
lectern of integrity all right a place
where shelton doesn't belong to my team
kelly jacket on with the team kelly
jacket it looks so nice nick's got the
team blake jacket
that's actually amazing
it's time for a game to test our lyrical
knowledge this is throw me a line
get it
get it jess all right we need a host so
heavenly father are you there hello
kelly hello nick hello john hello hello
guys everyone else
thanks for helping us out again so will
you refresh us on how this game works
gone well i certainly will uh i will
name a random song lyric from the middle
of a song now the first team to buzz in
and sing the title of the song gets the
point so if i say that saved a wretch
like me
you guys would buzz in and belt out
[Music]
if one team gets it wrong or takes too
long to answer the other team can steal
now if blake and nick win their photos
go up on the blake shelton wall of
champions
plus all the men in the audience will
get a prize now kelly if you and john
win all the ladies in the audience win
the prize and you can take blake's photo
off the wall and replace it with mine
yes
i replaced it with mine that's right
are you ready yes
john don't fail me why does blake have
tear drops on his because i i didn't
it's olivia munn okay yeah smile cry
smile now cry later uh okay good okay
i'm i'm so ready here we go this is your
first lyric where the whiskey drowns and
the beer chases where the whiskey drowns
and the beer chases my blues away
i'll be okay that's garth brooks um
friends and little players
[Music]
exactly high five all right that is
correct i hope he does another album
with that chris gaines i love that
my favorite it's so cute
okay here's the next one
clock strikes upon the hour and the sun
begins to fade clock strikes upon the
eye and the sun begins to fade that's
whitney houston that's
when the night falls
my lonely heart called
it i wanna dance with somebody that's it
all right i want to feel the heat i'm
feeling it
how will you know i know i'm feeling the
heat over here
i'm very good at this just so you know
your team sucks
and let me if you guys have fun
if you all see any if you all see any
coyotes in the studio you know what i'm
doing back here all right here we go now
here's your next one
to teach us gonna show you show you show
you how to get an a
um i know that how to get an a
a teacher's gonna show you how to get an
a
uh
how to get in there hey we get the point
cause i didn't know it's taking too long
taking too long you can steal come on is
that [ __ ] freeman
all right here we go i got it abc oh my
god that's the one
jackson five abc yeah i i completely
blazed why am i singing the lyric but i
don't know which song it is but kelly
and john you got two blake and nick you
had one so let's pick it up come on here
we go here's your next lyric
kick off your sunday's shoes please
louise pull me off monday of course not
a gotta cut loose
there it is
jack get back come on before we crack
that's about dancing for drugs or
something like that all right we're tied
right now
air horn triple air horn means we have
time for one more lyric so everybody
serious this is it this is the one
watch out here's your lyric okay a few
times i've been around that track so
it's confident around that track but i'm
not gonna have to happen right back
cause there ain't no holla back girl
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
i actually didn't mean to break
[Music]
you